all right well I think we'll go ahead
and get started
so hello everybody my name is Aaron
standard I'm um one of the creators of
aqua.net and in the sort of.net and
Technology space that's kind of what I'm
known for uh this talk will mention it
but it's not really about that it's
about software architecture and some
lessons that I've learned over the years
primarily by doing things wrong so we're
going to talk about
what I think is essentially a style of
well not really a style but more like a
philosophy of software architecture that
will save you a lot of time Agony and
most importantly money and risk down the
road
so what is technical debt
well technical debt is essentially when
you have a baked in let's say
architectural Choice made early on in
the life cycle of a project doesn't
necessarily have to be software if
anyone's tried installing CAT5 in a
really old house you know what technical
debt is like in the physical world
um
the idea behind this is that if we go
ahead and build let's say a large-scale
piece of enterprise software could be a
line of business application could be
something that's customer facing all of
them end up kind of in the same place
which is that let's say you go ahead and
build a database driven application
which is probably the most common style
of software application that's out there
you have your relational database that
has data that has table schema that has
stored procedures and Views and then on
top of that you go ahead and have let's
say your reporting and your object
relational mapping and then you might
have your UI layer then you have your
business processes that either your
customers or your internal stakeholders
use and then on top of that you have all
the historical data business value and
let's say built-in systems like human
run systems and expectations all resting
on top of that
so if you want to make a significant
change down here that is going to
propagate all the way up through all the
layers sitting on top of it that is the
essence of technical debt so if you
wanted to do something like
take a stored procedure that is 2 000
lines long and before you laugh and say
that's unbelievable uh no it's very
believable and happens way more often
than you think and probably involves
horrible stuff like CLR data types and
things like that
so if you want to make a change down
there you have to find a way to
essentially price that change in to all
the layers above it and that is
technical debt and that's where the
expense really comes from it's the
layering of basically additional layers
on top of lower ones right
so technical debt
when you're beginning with the Green
Field project it's like a newborn baby
it's totally innocent doesn't have any
history and has is nothing but pure
potential right that's sort of our Clean
Slate that we're starting with
well when you start making architectural
choices really early on in the project
that is where technical debt is going to
be born initially it begins right there
interest they kind of use a financial
analogy here
interest on your technical debt occurs
in the form of layering so if I make one
technical decision very early on the
life cycle of a project let's say it's
the decision to build for let's say we
take this back 10 15 years ago and I
decided to build my e-commerce system on
top of.net framework well that also
means that I've made a decision to keep
my infrastructure married to Windows it
means that all my developers need to buy
Visual Studio subscriptions and it means
that we're probably going to be you know
not able to this is all different now of
course these days but back then those
are some of the types of technical debt
that would accrue and you know other
ways that could potentially compound in
the future is in the form of let's say
unknown or unanticipated events that
arrive a good example I remember really
clearly of let's say
unanticipated technical debt with
the.net platform was back in around 2010
2011 web sockets first emerged on the
scene and this is one node.js was first
taking off and kind of becoming a
popular alternative to Ruby and asp.net
and other Technologies and one of the
things that helps node.js really take
off was it had by Far and Away the best
websocket support out of any platform
that existed at the time
well us.net developers were thinking wow
we would love to have all those same
benefits of server push but guess what
because our infrastructure is married to
Windows in order for us to get websocket
support we actually had to wait for a
Windows Server patch to get released and
that also required us to get an is patch
which required us to also update the
version of.net framework we're using and
required us to update the version of
asp.net and you kind of see that's an
example of an unanticipated change and
just something that kind of got priced
in it's still technical debt nonetheless
the purpose of this talk though is to
talk about technical debt you can
anticipate some new technology coming
out of left field in the browser space
and having and not knowing necessarily
how closely your web stack was married
to your operating system okay that's not
your fault but the failure to account
for problems you can easily see coming
down the road to five ten years in the
future that is something that you as an
architect need to price into your
designs sooner rather than later and
that's really kind of the essence of
optionality
technical debt it's full amount is kind
of expressed at the time you have to
make a change if you have to do
something like migrate from.net
framework to dot net six you're not
going to know what the full cost of that
is until you start getting into the
weeds and doing it right it's not very
easy to predict ahead of time
what we're going to talk about today is
this is a concept that originally is
kind of in finance it's known as
optionality uh stock options or Futures
contracts are really good examples of
optionality where someone can purchase a
call option it's a right to buy a stock
at a fixed price at some future point in
time call options are really useful if
you think that the value of a stock is
going to go up at some point in the
future or you know I'm from Houston this
is like the energy capital of the United
States people buy oil futures for
different types of petroleum products
and they do that in order to try to keep
their costs down they basically know I'm
going to be paying a hundred dollars a
barrel for a price of oil uh at you know
some point in the next 12 months and if
the price of oil goes beyond that I save
a whole bunch of money that way so the
idea is that I pay a premium today I
have to put in some money now to get
that future and then I have the right to
exercise it at you know basically up
until the option contract expires
in terms of software with optionality we
pay for optionality by planning ahead
and we exercise when we know that our
business and our software need to adjust
accordingly in order to meet some
business goal
so give you an example here
in terms of optionality
the further you are outside the circle
the more optionality you have in a green
field project you have nothing but
options no code is yet written no
infrastructure is yet picked unless you
have an I.T Department that's dogmatic
which some of us have
but no infrastructure is picked there's
no schema there's no customer data all
we have are our requirements and the set
of and basically our experience that's
the only real thing you're kind of
bringing into that project right
well once you start moving further down
let's say you get a new product that has
only a few users you still have a lot
more options for how you can make
changes to that product than you do if
you're in this middle circle right here
which is where you have a mission
critical product
you know so for example uh some of my
customers at Peta Bridge these are all
people building large-scale event-driven
applications some of their products are
responsible for I've got one customer
that basically has a manufacturing line
that is worth
probably close to let's say 50 billion
dollars on there and it's all being
automated by awka.net and a bunch of
other pieces of Technology they do not
have a huge amount of options for how
they want to change that because they
have to roll it out to a bunch of
factories and they have to change all
their business procedures and not to
mention the amount of disruption it
would cause if they did that so that's
an example of a product that doesn't
have a lot of options unless the
developers built them into their
architecture which is what we're going
to talk about
so the big idea behind optionality is
that when you're starting here with a
Greenfield project and you don't have
any constraints it's to plan ahead for
how your business might possibly change
in the future and being able to go ahead
and pay a little bit of Premium now in
order to make sure that adjusting to
those new business realities isn't a
tremendously expensive project later
right
so technical debt is basically the
destruction of optionalities what that
really is where if I have a whole bunch
of customer data and a bunch of business
processes and a bunch of built-in
Knowledge from let's say you know if
you're running an insurance business all
of the claims adjusters know how to use
your internal software today if you want
to radically change that you have to
retrain all of them that's not as simple
as just a software problem anymore it's
a big business issue
so the technical debt that we occur
typically happens when we fail to plan
for how software might evolve in the
future now I'm going to give you some
examples of that from my own personal
experience in just a second
um a really good example of like a
rapid-fire technical debt accumulation
tool is database driven development and
the reason why is that unless you are
really confident your requirements
aren't going to change or you have made
a really simple schema that's very fast
and very flexible you're going to
basically be bound by whatever the
development constraints are of that
database for a lot of applications that
will never realistically be an issue
because maybe there are auxiliary
systems that don't get changed very
often maybe they're very low traffic or
maybe they're in an area of your
business that's fairly stable and you're
not anticipating a lot of change in the
future however if you're from startup
world like I am where you're launching
let's say new products and you're not
totally sure what product Market fit
looks like meaning that your business is
probably going to adjust a bit over the
next couple years this can be a disaster
in the making and that is exactly what
happened to me and we'll get into that
in the next slide
ah these are some of my favorite Twitter
fights I get into about once a quarter
whoever needs to switch databases quick
show of hands in this room who has ever
switched a database before in a
production system
okay the few and the proud thank you
um switching databases should be rare if
you find yourself switching databases
every year please fire your architect
um but there are cases where that has to
be a viable solution and a lot of the
times the reason why people get into the
whoever needs to switch databases Camp
is because they've painted themselves
into a corner we're switching databases
is never a feasible option in other
words it's a self-fulfilling prophecy if
you believe that you should never have
to switch databases you never make the
you never create the options for that is
even viable
um on top of that things like the
repository pattern gets bashed all the
time probably because people try to make
a repository like a one-size-fits-all
thing that's not a great idea but
abstracting your data access layer
behind some common abstraction uh both
that's sort of let's say tailored to a
specific domain and very narrowly scoped
actually can be really valuable as a
former creating optionality and that'll
come up in my example
the basic idea behind this is that
future technical debt can be mitigated
by making some architectural choices
today
so I'm going to use an example from my
last company marked up we did real-time
analytics and marketing automation for
developers who are building apps for the
windows storm so Windows 8 Windows phone
and eventually uh win32 desktop
applications
so we're a real-time analytics startup
um we originally this is like 2000 yeah
2012. we originally built our minimum
viable product so our first go to market
Solution on top of ravendb using their
mapreduce indices these worked great for
doing real-time Analytics
and I had read ayinde's blog post
basically knocking the repository
pattern and calling it an anti-pattern
you shouldn't use it blah blah blah so I
bought in on that you know Hook Line and
Sinker and basically went and had Raven
DB calls everywhere in our system in our
right pipeline in our reporting system
in our user registration system uh we
basically said you know why bother
having a repository Allende is right
this is you know going to be a a way to
make sure we don't have unnecessary
abstractions inside our system
well as I mentioned down here we were
way more successful with our early
customer acquisition efforts than I
thought we went from about
ten thousand events per day and just in
our analytic system to about five to
eight million events per day in the span
of a three-day window
so that's like a what four hundred
percent uh like day over day increase
for three days in a row and the amount
of traffic that we are producing should
have been something that Raven DB could
handle but alas it could not
as a result of some of our architecture
decisions our database logic was spread
out everywhere
and Raven DB could not basically keep
our reports up to date and this was
during a critical window where we were
raising Venture Capital money and trying
to basically prove to the market that we
had a viable solution so I was staying
up until four o'clock in the morning and
getting up at 10 A.M the following day
for about three weeks trying to
basically furiously pay off this
technical debt so we could successfully
complete our fundraise and not lay
everybody off
so the real risk here was because we
hadn't taken made any effort to isolate
our database this decision away from the
rest of our domain logic around
transforming events managing customer
data and so forth and we had also
depended on a raven DB specific feature
these mapreduce indices both of those
choices coupled us very tightly to our
database and there was nothing we could
do to make Raven scale we even wrote Our
Own replication system and our own
database migration system because
Raven's built-in tooling utterly failed
at both so we threw everything we could
at that and we had a uh I think a 64
core database instance trying to go
ahead and process all this and if I
showed you the graph what we basically
saw was CPU utilization at 100 percent
disk utilization at 100 memory at like 1
12 the amount it should be using it
basically wasn't using memory very
efficiently
so this created a really high risk
situation for our business and we had to
basically do an emergency migration off
of ravendb to something more scalable
otherwise our business would fail and we
would not be able to successfully
complete our fundraise
so here's what we did
in the span of about yeah three to four
weeks we refactored our system uh to an
event-driven processing model is what we
did and I created a piece of middleware
that could take all the events the
clients were sending to our HTTP API
that was another form of technical debt
but in this case it didn't really affect
us too bad uh we had to make sure the
same events that were already embedded
in those apps could get reprocessed in a
new system and produce the same reports
so we created some middleware that could
translate those events into an analytic
Delta basically it's a sort of a way of
incrementing a counter without knowing
what its full value is
and we separated our read and write
models into discrete services that were
abstracted away essentially repositories
uh well services plus repositories
internally
um the other thing that we couldn't
really do very well with our original
implementation is because we were so
closely married to our database we
didn't really have the ability to unit
test we had to integration test
everything with the Raven DB local
instance up and running which again made
it very difficult for us to start making
this change trying to move towards a
database system that'd be more scalable
so we were able to add unit tests back
because we had effectively abstracted
away our persistence layer now
um we created a little DSL that allowed
Dynamic per user filtering of events
that was super useful and greatly
improved our developer throughput the
database we switched to in case
someone's at wondering is Apache
Cassandra which is a big super right
heavy system that's great at real-time
analytics and we were able to replace
most of Raven's functionality uh there
were a couple things we couldn't really
do that we had to defer for a basically
another project in a future day but this
helped us quite a bit and allowed us to
get past these scaling challenges and to
scale horizontally going forward so what
did we do differently here
well basically we decided that you know
what we're not going to
repeat the same mistake of putting all
our eggs in one basket with one database
solution when we eventually would reach
a scale we were doing about 100 million
events today from millions of concurrent
users in the span of like a three hour
window in the U.S
so thankfully Cassandra was able to
scale with that but we were hedging our
bets that you know what if if Cassandra
started having problems and we started
reaching the 100 million billion you
know sort of area we wanted to have the
ability to move to something else if we
needed to that became a valuable option
for us given the types of scaling issues
we were dealing with on top of that we
really wanted to have unit testing and
kind of keep our business logic around
Computing Deltas completely isolated
from the database
the real issue here is that software
developers in terms of what the modern
consensus is around software design is
you ain't going to need it build for
your requirements today anything I've
worked with regard to Future
requirements is tomorrow use problem
right future you they can figure it out
well that is a really catastrophically
stupid decision in a lot of cases and
the reason why is that yagni comes with
an expiration date you are it really
should be you are eventually going to
need it probably
good example if I'm launching an
e-commerce startup and I go ahead and
marry all of my business processes and
designs to let's say stripe for doing my
credit card processing and subscriptions
that's probably fine for the first
several years of my startups business
right but if at some point in the future
I want to expand into India or other
countries where stripe isn't the best
processor or there's a local processor
that works better or if I want to try to
switch to a different processor to
reduce my charge fees so I can actually
get more profit per transaction if I'm
totally married to stripe and everything
in my API and in my data system is all
stripe Centric that is going to be an
enormously expensive project down the
road whereas if I design my payment
processor system to be inherently
plugable from day one that becomes a
much more achievable project in the
future adding a new payment provider to
service customers and this geography or
at or replacing stripe for new customers
in the future to lower my credit card
fees and that's a requirement you can
easily anticipate if you're going into
that business that you know what there
will be some point when the business
asks us to support a new credit card
processor that's inevitable in any sort
of you know e-commerce customer facing
business we need to build in the option
to do that when we're first getting
started not engage in a giant you know
emergency fire drill sort of uh hair on
fire exercise like we did at marked up
so let's talk about high optionality
programming what are some techniques
that will generally speaking preserve
optionality a lot better than things
like crud for instance crud does not
really preserve optionality so what are
some techniques that will help us do
that
well this isn't a exhaustive list these
are the big ones that in my personal
experience have helped me a lot and any
project where I did not start with this
I eventually ended up there through an
expensive refactoring exercise that I'm
trying to help you avoid
so event driven programming is probably
the dominant one followed by event
sourcing cqrs actors naturally and
extend only design
let's talk about event driven
programming first and how that preserves
optionality
well if I have let's say a traditional
RPC service let's say an HTTP API or you
know uh maybe some most types of grpc
services I basically send a request and
I get a response back from the same
server I was talking to
and you know that's one of the Mill web
application development
with an event driven system
I have a lot more inherent flexibility
in the communication models between my
client and my server than I do with an
RPC system with our PC you're
essentially limited to request response
that's the communication pattern that
you get maybe you could also do one way
on there you could do fire and forget
messaging by just returning a HTTP
response before you do any processing
but it's all in essence request response
with an event driven system you have a
lot more different possible messaging
patterns out there than merely request
response for example down here this is
what a publish And subscribe messaging
pattern might look like you have a
client sends one message to the server
and it can get a infinite stream of
responses as things happen in real time
later and the technology you can use to
implement this is pretty diverse you
could use in-service bus you could use
awka.net you could use Orleans or you
could use something like grpc to do that
if you wanted to so I have a lot more
choices around how things work with an
inherently event driven system gives me
more possible patterns and tools to
leverage than a simple RPC system does
now the idea behind events let me pause
here for a second
yeah
there we go
the idea behind events
there we go is that in essence
um they have additional properties
Beyond let's say just the simple payload
so you do have the payload that's your
datum but you also usually have a reply
to address now that can be explicitly
exposed like it would be in a octod.net
system but it might also be implicit via
something like rapidmq where you might
have a reply to channel on there and you
don't necessarily know who's listening
to it
um that's sort of the the first bit
messaging and event driven systems are
almost always asynchronous so when you
go ahead and pass an event somewhere you
might be given a task you can a weight
on uh if you want to do requests uh
request response style over a message
driven system but you don't have to most
often these systems tend to be pretty
fire and forget I write a message in a
rabbitmq I get an acknowledgment that
the message is queued and then I don't
worry about who's processing it I move
on and go back to the rest of my work
that gives us a lot of flexibility
around how processing is done and most
importantly
with messaging is that the messages are
always stored and serialized so there's
actually a real object you can point to
that correlates to this request an HTTP
request is a transient in-flight object
that has a real-time limit associated
with it that's your timeout value right
well with messaging you're a little bit
more flexible you have this serialized
message body and it can be processed
immediately if you have let's say a
bunch of competing consumers all trying
to drain a queue or it could be
processed over and over again in the
future if you have a tool like Apache
Kafka where you have arbitrary clients
and arbitrary groups that read
partitions over and over again
it's a lot more flexible than what an
RPC system can do
on top of that message oriented systems
have the ability to change the order and
which requests are processed in a you
know HTTP or RPC system everything's got
to be processed live right now you don't
necessarily have the ability to reorder
uh how those HTTP requests are processed
and the message driven system this is
really trivial the recipient of the
message can say okay before I process
this message I need to wait for this one
to arrive because that has the data I
need in order to process this request
and this is what we would call a
deferral in a message processing system
in a tool like akka.net you would use
Behavior switching and stashing to do
that and then the most powerful property
of an event driven system is that events
can be forwarded delegated or even
broadcast to multiple parties you can't
do that with a request or the function
call so the fact that you have this
artifact this message that has possibly
unique ID it can be serialized into a
byte array and can be shared across
multiple parties is an inherently more
flexible programming model than what a
purely procedural sort of application is
going to look like
and so in terms of the interaction
patterns for a message driven system
these are going to be inherently more
diverse than what you get with RPC I can
have a broadcast interaction where one
party publishes its message to many
receivers this opens the door for all
sorts of interesting communication
patterns in a you know distributed
system I can do a proxy pattern this is
basically how you delegate work inside
an event driven system where I can hand
off the responsibility for processing a
message from one party to another if I
want to and then we also have
relationships like publish And subscribe
where I can kind of invert control and
the client basically receives
notifications from the server when State
changes rather than the client having to
pull the server for those changes you
know repeatedly down the road so the
first sort of tool we're going to use
for kind of limiting our technical debt
accumulation there we go
yeah one-way messaging the first tool
the first kind of stop is using an event
driven architecture generally speaking
event driven architectures scale really
well with domain complexity and they buy
you a lot more freedom in the future if
you need to change how processing is
done a procedural system is going to be
much harder to adjust because it's not
inherently flexible in the same way that
this is the other reason why we want to
look at event driven architectures is it
lends itself really well to the second
third and fourth patterns which is event
sourcing
why does event sourcing help us mitigate
technical debt well this is how they Ock
it up resistance works for instance
where we go ahead and we process
messages in the order in which we
receive them initially for a single
actor and a single actor represents like
one business entity Insider system so if
I'm keeping track of let's say session
state for a user and I want to see what
sorts of things that user might be
looking at on our e-commerce site so I
can try to personalize a recommendation
for them in real time I might be
receiving a stream of Click events here
inside the actor for that user and I
have an in-memory representation of that
user's click stream right
well every single time we go and
communicate with that actor that actor
has an in-memory copy of that state but
that state is also being event sourced
one click stream event at a time to
whatever our database is and our
database could be SQL could be Azure
table storage it's not really relevant
it all kind of looks like a key value
store inside this system
now how does this go and preserve
optionality for US versus let's say just
writing rows or modifying object
modifying a document in mongodb or
inserting a row into SQL
well Yep this is how we go and replay it
the reason why is that event sourcing
inherently lends itself to providing a
complete history of how something
changed it gives us the ability to see
that the user did this did that did that
and that and that leads to their current
state whatever that is right now that
state could be a recommendation for what
sorts of products we should show that
user that state could be the account
balance for a bank account that state
could be the current state of a device
operating a process line control system
in a factory doesn't really necessarily
matter it works for any domain
but
the state can always be rebuilt by
replaying previous events this means
that your current state the current
application state of your objects is
something that you can reprogram on the
fly without having to touch your data if
you want to if you want to make an
update to the code that reconstitutes
your state it's really easy to do that
because it is effectively separate from
the data the data is all those past
events they were immutable they are at
rest inside your database somewhere and
you can't change what they mean right
but you can go ahead and change how you
basically constitute those events in
order to represent the state of your
object so a good example if we change
the types of let's say um
types of bank accounts that we support
in our banking system and I want to have
the ability to show pending transactions
and pending account balances as
separately from the posted balance I
could reasonably do that by adding a new
event type that represents pending
operations and replaying all my old
types and I'll have in one section the
current balance and then the pending
balance and that doesn't require me to
do a dangerous data migration or
anything else at all because all those
old events that represent the user's
account history are still there inside
the database
so the way the state is built can be
changed without changing the events
themselves that is a very powerful
option
another powerful option again I'll use a
financial example is that historical
events can be replayed and reused in new
forms aside from what your application
does you can use them for things like
simulations or predictions or you can
even use them for validating a future
version of the application for instance
one of the ways they do testing of
really complex pieces of software like
massively multiplayer online RPGs is by
replaying a saved game over the new
client the reason why is it's not
possible to go ahead and write unit
tests for every possible interaction
that can happen between players so you
want to go and take all the different
let's say events that occurred over the
course of a game session and replay them
through the new client and look for
unanticipated changes regressions that
might occur there really easy to do that
with an Event Source system we use this
for regression testing future versions
of marked up actually we use it for
doing a combination of load testing and
also making sure that our analog system
work correctly these same events with
the new code should still produce the
same total values as the old one
lastly another option that event
sourcing gives us
is the ability to safely introduce new
event types without modifying existing
data the immutability of existing
customer and business data is actually a
really important selling point from the
riskiness of a system how many of you
have had a automated database migration
go wrong in a production system before
let's all be honest it can happen and
that's basically as a result of the fact
that you're changing an object in a way
that is not intrinsically safe is what's
going on there you're doing some sort of
destructive action against your schema
migration potentially we're going to
address how to manage that issue in the
final section which is extend only
design we'll get to that in a moment but
event sourcing naturally lends itself to
that type of extension as well
the other sort of thing that's
inherently useful about event sourcing
is that typically it relies on really
simple key value store architectures
this means that you can actually use
event sourcing with pretty much any
database out there even something really
simple like Azure table storage will
work fine
so you're not basically using
um
super let's say bespoke database
features that don't translate very well
to another database in the event that
you needed to migrate in the future and
honestly something that's pretty simple
and robust like postgres will probably
scale just fine for a really large Event
Source system because again we're using
really simple constructs there's no left
outer joins against synthetic tables in
here right
now the next pattern that we're going to
get to and these all kind of uh compile
on top of each other is cqrs command and
query responsibility segregation
the idea behind this if you're not
familiar with cqrs is basically to
separate your read and write models from
each other uh one mistake that a lot of
developers often make is having their
read and write models be the exact same
thing and the reason why that doesn't
work is the way
there's impedance mismatch but the other
potential issue with it is is that
certain databases are faster at
performing reads and they are performing
rights and if your system becomes
increasingly write heavy trying to have
reads and rights use the same model is
going to create a lot of inherent
friction and tension inside the system
so the idea behind this is essentially
your right models should be optimized
for rights your read models should be
optimized for reads now you have a lot
of flexibility on how you produce a read
model from your rights that's something
you can do inside your application it's
something you could do with a database
feature like like a view if you wanted
to a materialized view
but
the basic gist behind this is that you
should optimize your models separately
so in the case of let's say our Event
Source system it's optimized for super
fast super simple rights that can be
done at high rates of speed even in a
relational database like SQL Server
which is traditionally a little bit
slower handling rights than something
like mongodb or redis perhaps
but with our read models we can go ahead
and build something that's a lot richer
and a lot closer to the type of
requirements your business users might
actually want so if you want to have a
really nice reporting system or you want
to go ahead and use you know SQL Server
analysis services to produce a nice data
Cube your read models are what really
handle that and they are kept separate
from your right models and usually you
have a processor that will go ahead and
either materialize the the read View at
the time the shortly after the ride
occurs or you might use a database
feature to go and do that potentially
the uh the real big benefit from an
optionality point of view here is that
you can always change your read models
independently from the data that's at
rest you can always essentially rerun
your projection process and recreate
those on the Fly there's synthetic data
in other words right the thing we're
trying to avoid doing with event
sourcing and cqrs is taking the valuable
business data we've already recorded and
touching it in a potentially destructive
way that's what we're trying to avoid
from a business risk perspective
gqrs helps us do that by making sure
that all of our read models can
essentially be reproduced on the fly
when we need to because all the data
that was written is still there and it's
not inherently modified as part of our
projection process here
the next option that we get out of this
is that the performance characteristics
for read and write models can be tuned
separately if you need to we might need
to have a super efficient right model
for being able to handle lots of you
know let's say millions of operations
per second potentially but our read
model needs to be optimized for
maybe being able to take a fairly large
amount of data and compress it into a
really small HTTP response size or a
really small analytic Delta we serve up
over signalr something like that you
have the ability to kind of performance
tune each of these individually which is
really useful on top of that
not just tuning the performance but also
tuning how human friendly they are your
right model should probably be machine
friendly if you care about performance
if you care about not getting fired your
read model should be human friendly
that makes sense
all right
and then yeah on top of that you can
actually potentially use separate
databases for reads and rights if you
want to a good example of that we had a
customer that does uh really super
detailed financial reporting for like
government compliance and they use
basically an Event Source system on top
of postgres for doing all of their
inbound inbound rights and we used
basically kind of a
don't hate me for this we use an Entity
framework sort of schema for actually
going and producing the real reports
Auditors would use inside their system
and that was done all on top of postgres
as well but I could very easily have
done that on SQL Server if I needed to
there would have been very little cost
to doing that
the last thing I go ahead and mention as
far as the event as the sort of event
driven part is actors actors are Dynamic
and they give you the ability to kind of
partition how you process streams of
events that are inside your system so
for instance I can go ahead and have one
actor per business entity that's being
updated in real time I can have
stateless actors that perform tasks like
sending transactional emails or writing
to the database or calling a web API
they're inherently flexible pieces of
code that are designed to be run in
parallel with lots of other instances of
themselves in order to achieve maximum
throughput and CPU utilization
well what makes actors useful from an
optionality standpoint is their dynamism
it's the fact that we can basically
change where work is happening and how
work is done on the fly as we're
receiving events in real time
this is what a simple akadona actor
looks like for instance we have a little
base type this receive actor and then we
have some state in this case my state is
just our logging system handle and then
we have the different types of message
handlers that we're processing and these
messages are can be sent in memory or
they can be sent over the network
akka.net doesn't care and that's kind of
invisible to you as the end user
and then you have some C sharp code or F
sharp code optionally in here for being
able to do processing and in this case
I'm scheduling a delayed reply back to
the sender here if I just called
sender.tel I'll be replying to them back
in real time
one of the things that this actor can do
I'll skip this part
one of the things the actors can
inherently do is change their behavior
at runtime as they're processing a
message I can say instead of processing
we'll go back here
instead of processing this ping message
using this function changed using this
function instead until we get this
critical event that we're waiting for so
imagine building something like a state
machine for some part of your business
if you're doing something like
transactional processing for an
e-commerce system you might say okay the
first thing we need to do is submit the
payment information to our payment
Gateway and see if that result comes
back successfully if that result doesn't
come back successfully we have a whole
error flow we need to go through where
we let the user know why their card was
declined we probably have to send them
an email we probably still have to
preserve everything in their cart or
maybe we might schedule a quick retry to
see if it goes through a second time
right whatever the case may be and if
the credit card transaction goes through
successfully then we have a fulfillment
process the actor is going to start
running through where we might talk to
our fulfillment server and make sure
that there's a entry for getting this
product loaded into our shipping partner
and getting that out the door and actors
can basically switch Behavior really
quickly with a very minimal a code in
order to handle these types of cases
this is a lot simpler because it's all
self-contained inside one object that
owns this unit of work that it is trying
to coordinate that across a whole bunch
of different microservices or a whole
bunch of different procedural classes
that are all spread out
so the ability for us to kind of
dynamically shift How We Do processing
in real time is very powerful exists the
ability to compress what could be an
enormous amount of business logic into a
relatively small amount of code
so actors and optionality
well one of the things they also make
possible is the ability to query your
live application State at runtime if you
want to if I want to basically know what
is the total amount of orders that are
being processed right now that is very
trivial to implement with actors doing
that with database driven development
would probably require you to maintain a
whole separate set of calls to redis
where you need to keep update or
increment a counter decrement it then
you have to go ahead and basically add
an error handling and retrying if that
query doesn't go through whereas with
actors you can just run a quick
um
there's actually a number that gets
exposed in aqua.net you can just pull to
see how many actors are alive right now
it also makes stateful server-side
applications viable one of my biggest
complaints about database driven
development is it's inherently stateless
all of it which is fine for probably I'd
say the vast majority of applications
but the most critical ones in your
business will often need to have some
measure of state in order to do things
like keep request processing times low
if you want to build an application that
can build let's say something like a
real-time Banner ad exchange or
real-time chat system or real-time you
know let's say Fleet Management System
you need State inside your application
to make that achievable actors are a
Pitch Perfect way of doing that inside
your system whether you use akka.net
Orleans doesn't really matter it's just
the general Paradigm is really useful at
giving you that set of tools to do it
the other thing is that like we talked
about event processing can become
Dynamic rather than having a static set
of functions that are inherently
stateless handling our business logic
and our work we have entities that are
responsible for recovering their own
State making decisions about what to do
with events in real time based on what
their state is and they have the ability
to dynamically do things like reroute a
message somewhere else stash it and
process it later once we get a critical
event that arrives or broadcast it to
multiple parties over our Network all
these different event driven paradigms
you discussed earlier are all very
inexpensive to implement with actors and
don't require very much infrastructure
either
um the other thing is that actors have
the ability to basically be distributed
over a network with very with
essentially no code changes
um actors tend to be location
transparent which means that if an actor
moves from one process onto another as a
result of let's say the other process
being shut down that's not going to have
a tremendous amount of impact on your
code that's a routine thing actors can
handle it's just like you know basically
if you were to rebalance a Kafka
partition or add a new web server under
your load balancer it's more or less the
same sort of automated process for doing
that
the last subject I'll touch on for being
able to preserve optionality is what we
call extend only design now I have a
full blog post that goes into a lot more
detail on how to do this on my personal
website and I'll talk about that at the
end but if you're doing database driven
development this is the one pattern you
can Implement today that will help you a
lot in terms of preserving optionality
in your system this does not require you
to do an event driven architecture this
does not require you to use actors you
can do this with SQL server today
extendedly design is a methodology for
making sure that there are no
incompatible changes ever made to your
SQL schema at any point in the present
moving forward it's basically a way of
preserving backwards and forwards
compatibility
the idea is that your schema your wire
format so if you're doing serialization
that's what we're referring to there and
apis are frozen for updates or deletes
if you want to make a change to your
HTTP endpoint you're going to have to
either introduce a new method where
you're going to need to introduce a new
version where that has a separate URI
prefix than what you had before which is
basically how people version public web
apis typically so no destructive changes
are allowed you're not allowed to change
how something worked you're not allowed
to rename or repurpose something you're
not allowed to delete stuff anything
that is being used by live stakeholders
or being used by live clients stays
Frozen as is
new things can always be added this is
the extension part you can always add
new stuff that wasn't being used before
you can add a new HTTP endpoint you can
add a new message type to your event
Source system you can add a new table
you can add a new column to an existing
table
you just can't go back and change the
past you can basically change something
that's currently being used or currently
has data in it that you know will be
used
so old schema will be gradually made
obsolete as the software updates if we
have some old SQL schema that we want to
get rid of we can't delete it but we can
gradually stop using it and then maybe
we could go back and delete it if we
wanted to but that process takes a
little while you have to kind of age out
of your system
so why is extend only design useful it
eliminates an entire risk category for
updating your software in the future and
an entire area where technical debt gets
created The Accidental destruction of
business value and on top of that the
unknown unknowns of gee what happens if
I go through and change the schema on
this table how many different calls are
there to that table that I can't trace
inside all the various applications that
talk to it that's something that can be
to a degree unknowable inside your
application therefore it's risky to make
those destructive changes with extend
only design you avoid that entire
problem because you're not fundamentally
changing the stuff that's already in use
you're just adding new things that
updated clients and updated consumers
will use down the road
so a good example of like how we manage
versioning and like occodontist internal
message formats we use Google protobuf
for all of our internal message types
and protobuf lends it really well to
this type of extend only design
so for instance I might have a little
protobuf message that looks like this
where okay I've got these five
properties here and I want to add a
sixth property for figuring out if this
user made this type of stock trading
operation and ask I want to see this
person did this ask using margin meaning
they borrowed money from us in order to
buy that stock
uh okay did this person make this
actually not to buy the stock to sell it
in this case so they might be shorting
or something
so this is a new field this new field
can be added to this protobuf message
and that protobuf message can be
recompiled into C sharp without breaking
wire compatibility if I go and I'm
running this node in the cluster using
this new version of the message all the
older nodes that don't have that
definition for that field will see some
unrecognized property and just ignore it
now
that's not great from a data loss
standpoint but it's a lot better than
the alternative which might be bricking
the rest of the entire cluster as soon
as that first node joints right so this
ability to extend all this extend only
design ability gives us both forward and
backwards compatibility
in the backwards Direction
if my new client gets an old message
from one of the old node types it can
substitute a default value for that new
optional property okay if I'm getting a
trade order from an old client that
doesn't support margin
guess what that trade can't be done with
margin therefore we're going to say that
property is false Insider application
our serializer will go ahead and just
use a safe default value there if you're
building something like a extend only
designed with SQL schema you might have
a default value you specify for for
basically pre-existing for a rows that
didn't have that new column you're
adding so it might be null might be a
good example or maybe if you're using an
integer the value is 0 or negative one
whatever kind of makes sense for your
use case
but the idea behind this is that by
using extend only design
we preserve our old schema and we don't
have to account for all the different
parts of our application that might be
talking to it we can go ahead and add
the new functionality we need without
destroying the old functionality that
other clients might use and because the
new client knows how to substitute a
safe default value for areas where that
new data may not be available old
clients and new clients can continue to
interact with each other safely over a
longer period of time
on top of that this also means you can
actually update your database schema
independently from your application I
can roll out my schema update well in
advance of the application that uses it
so I don't have to have an Entity
framework migration running live in my
CI CD pipeline our dbas can stage it
execute it see it roll out and then the
application can get deployed you know
that day or the following day if you
want to it effectively decouples those
two activities together and lowers the
risk of a deployment failing or a
customer and business data being
destroyed
uh yeah
on top of that extend only design is a
great way to guarantee zero downtime
deployments um I imagine that a lot of
you have the ability to take your
systems offline and have downtime when
you do a really big deployment but if
you work in Industries like software as
a service or maybe doing things like you
know manufacturing you want to try to
avoid downtime to the extent that it's
possible because that represents a
business outage and lost revenue and
potentially mad customers extendedly
designed is an absolute must-have if
that's important to you being able to
essentially eliminate downtime in your
deployments
so extend only down extend only design
will help you tremendously
now what do these patterns all have in
common these high optionality patterns
what's the essence of this programming
methodology well immutability is
probably the foremost concern here which
is that one state is written somewhere
it can't its meaning can't be changed
and it can't be destroyed unless you're
being really intentional about it no
accidental side effects on data is what
we're trying to avoid here so
immutability kind of sits at the
Forefront of all these patterns it's all
about trying to conserve the basically
the old datum in perpetuity for future
use we're basically assuming data
storage is cheap and honestly compared
to software development time it really
is
so we're going more than happy to go
ahead and trade a larger SQL Server
instance in exchange for our developers
not having to spend hundreds of man
years you know rewriting a piece of
production code
dynamism is another thing that we're
trying to preserve here uh we want to go
ahead and dynamically route process and
react to State changes in real time
systems that are more static are
inherently less flexible and require a
lot more effort on the part of the
developer to update systems that are
inherently Dynamic from the get-go like
event driven architectures or actors are
going to be easier to do on kind of an
ad hoc basis over time
and lastly we kind of separated our
concerns to some degree each of these
patterns kind of addresses different
facets of software actors are all about
how we process the system events are all
about how we organize interactions
between domains event sourcing is how we
write cqrs is how we read Etc these are
all different sort of facets of our of
our application programming models but
when we put them all together we end up
with a system that's going to make be
easier to change down the road and
easier to evolve there is cost to doing
this for instance extend only design
requires a lot more planning and
enforcement from a CI CD perspective
than
YOLO crud or whatever people do by
default so there is a cost to doing this
and that's the premium when it comes to
options but the value is you get that
flexibility to evolve your system
naturally in the future in a way that's
going to be much less expensive and more
importantly much less risky than what
you might be doing today
so just to recap
technical debts the destruction of
options that's really what it is when
technical debt gets created you're
basically destroying a viable future
option as a result of making a choice
that is basically not flexible it's the
idea behind it
um
High optionality architectures yeah I
just mentioned this they tend to cost a
bit more to develop up front that is
absolutely true that is the trade-off
basically that you're basically spending
more time and money initially in your
design but they'll pay for themselves
very quickly if your business evolves
and then on top of that you're really
high optionality architectures are
things you should do if you anticipate
change being likely in your business
over a long enough time Horizon change
is inevitable that will happen but there
are you know cases where the application
you're working on is probably pretty
stable and the likelihood of it changing
significantly is low in those cases you
should feel free to use whatever you
think is going to be the most expedient
to getting the job done but most really
critical business pieces of business
software more than likely they're going
to change and if you want to enable your
business to be agile and to be able to
react quickly to those changes and you
as a software developer if you want to
be happy and not bitching about Legacy
code all the time high optionality
architecture is a really good investment
and I would start by learning the event
driven part of it first is probably
where I'd begin or if you want to get
started with something right away think
about freezing your schema and applying
extend only design to it that's
something you can do without
re-architecting your software so let's
start with that I think about changing
how your cic D processes and your
deployment systems might look if you did
that
so that's it for my talk today if you go
to petabridge.com you can see my
original uh articles I wrote about high
optionality architecture and then my
handle is Aaron on the web I tweeted out
some links to all of my more detailed
articles on things like extend only
design you can go ahead and find that on
there as well so thank you very much for
your time and I'll be happy to take some
questions
so you show hands yes
absolutely
so we use like it up persistent in my in
our system we use Aqueduct resistance
query to do projections where
essentially I have actors that tail the
events that are being persisted into a
materialized view and how granular that
view might be can really really kind of
depends on the domain I'm working in
um I might do a per entity let's say
rock it up persistence query that spins
up tails the events live as they come in
writes it all out into let's say a
document or a set of SQL rows and then
if I make a really significant change
the way our view models work I might go
and introduce a totally new set of
projection actors to do that
any other questions yes
yes
so the question just to repeat it for
everyone here is how do you sell a
upfront higher cost design methodology
like optionality to startups the
companies the fewest resources and the
greatest likelihood of change
um so I have made two really crucial
mistakes with products I've owned where
marked up was one of them and I've got a
second one that we're currently still
struggling with actually where we
basically did a minimum viable product
so get something to Market quickly that
meets all the basic requirements of your
customers and we were a little bit too
minimal and not enough viable basically
it was the kind of the issue there
the argument you should make for high
optionality architecture is that not
doing this is betting against your
success
that's the the line you got to say there
look if you think you're going to be
successful build it like you mean it if
you don't think you're going to be
successful why are you in this business
you know go do web you know
cryptocurrency or AI or something right
next question
pivot oh yeah yeah basically that's
another good argument is that high
optionality increases the likelihood of
successful pivot you know when you do
make that transition from
um you know nfts to AI tools you know
that'll be really a really good selling
point for that
um I hate that I keep knocking the
startup industry those poor guys are
having a rough time right now
any other questions
yes
so do we
um okay that's a good question so extend
only design is what you're referring to
right so does extend only design
introduce technical debt and my answer
to that question is no it doesn't what
it does leave behind is a lot of
cellular waste some to some extent some
old tables and old code that may not be
used anymore and once you're certain
that that's not being used actively
anywhere in your application you can
safely get rid of that stuff it's just
that the bet you're making is you know
what in a large enough company with a
large enough application with a lot of
different services using it the moment I
deploy a new piece of schema I am not
100 certain what all the interactions of
that table or that API or that piece of
data look like so I'm going to make the
bet that there are some systems out
there still using it the old way
therefore I want to go ahead and take
eliminate the risk that that's going to
cause a you know category five shitstorm
inside our Ops Department that day right
so the extended only design is basically
a way of lowering the risk on a per
deployment basis
um the one thing that extendedly design
will do is it'll force you to basically
try to enforce some rules in your CI CD
pipeline to eliminate really destructive
actions so I'll give you an example of
how we do that in the occodontic project
we use a tool called a verify which is
basically a way of doing snapshot
testing and we do an entire printout of
what our public API looks like we render
it as a giant string basically and that
gets written to a text file that gets
checked into Source control verify will
let us know if someone went through and
let's say added a new argument to a
Constructor that is actually technically
a breaking change right even if they
made that argument optional and that's
not binary compatible and that means
that every plugin built on older
versions of akka.net will break until it
upgrades which is something we
explicitly do not allow in our
versioning system except under very
special circumstances
well that allows us so we basically have
a habit as software developers are going
and checking like ah nope can't do that
not allowed to make that change unless
you do it in a way that's safe we have
instructions written down on how to do
that you would need to check in a
snapshot of something like your SQL
schema for instance
to go and make sure okay this person did
not drop the orders table by accident or
this person did not do whatever tools
like an automatic Entity framework code
first migration should seem terrifying
to you because you have no idea if you
don't emit the output what it's really
doing under the covers until it's
starting to happen right
so that's sort of something you're going
to have to incorporate into your build
system a little bit uh ditto with things
like managing your wire format if you're
using a tool like akka.net or Kafka
where you're doing a serialization of
message types that's another thing
you'll want to check into Source control
and make sure there's a step where
someone has to review that before it
gets merged in
uh any other questions
yes go ahead
yes
so what do I mean the question was when
I talk about partitioning of events
using actors or really you could do it
with any sort of Q anything like even a
Kafka client can be partitioned uh what
does that mean partitioning means if you
have a giant fire hose of events rather
than having a single class basically
responsible for processing all of them
you have the ability to basically divide
that giant let's say fire hose of events
into smaller streams that are organized
by maybe the entity type or maybe by the
entity ID itself so let's say if I have
a thousand users on my website I might
partition The Click stream for all
thousand users into a thousand little
streams one for each user anaka.net can
route those messages to the single
entity actor that owns that individual
user that's really what we mean by
partitioning is sort of breaking up the
big stream into like manageable Parts
essentially
any other questions
well hey thanks for the great questions
and thank you everyone for attending I
really appreciate it uh I'll be I'll be
around I've got another talk on Friday
morning on.net systems programming if
you're interested but otherwise thank
you very much for your time I really
appreciate it
[Applause]